hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel as always my name is caleb denby
and today
we're going to be taking a look at
another step on yon napomnishi's
uh path to the world championship so in
this game he was playing his
russian compatriot uh camille alexeyenko
uh and jan had the white pieces
and at this point the uh chasers were
sort of nipping at yon's heels yon
really needed a win
to maintain his advantage in the
tournament and that's exactly what he
manages to pull off here
let's see how we did it so yawn starts
with c4
we get knight f6 g3 e6
bishop g2 and d5 so so far so normal
black is doing one of the most common
setups against d4 or c4
alike you simply develop the knight and
stake your claim in the center
with the pawn on d5 now we get knight f3
by yan and the downside to this move
order
in the catalan or english whatever you
want to call it
it's in english but it can transpose to
a catalan the downside
is that by moving this bishop here so
quickly and by
not playing d4 for so long sometimes d
takes c4 can be a nice way to equalize
with the black pieces now we do see the
move queen a4 check
by uh yan napongishi we get knight b to
d7
and queen takes c4 so so far this is
still pretty
normal well-trodden territory in catalan
uh now we get a6 by alexenko and this
tends to be
the remedy for uh the the catalan
and the early queen a4 check type of
lines
now why is this move so good against the
queen a4 check lines well
because this queen is unfortunately
placed on c4
black is threatening to break out with
the move b5
with tempo in many positions for example
if white were to castle here
simply the move b5 queen c2 and bishop
b7
would leave alexenko with absolutely no
problems and that's sort of the feeling
i get for the entirety
of the open catalan if black can get
away with playing b5 without any big
problems
and then followed up with bishop b7
light's main advantage in the form of
this strong bishop on g2
is entirely nullified and the game is
more or less equal
so let's see how jan manages to navigate
this battle
over the break of b5 first and foremost
yan
just moves the queen out of the way now
b5 of course would be a massive blunder
because
knight e5 is the nasty idea that jan has
of course we can move the rook out of
the way but don't go
too quickly here this queen is actually
trapped along with the fork
so b5 no longer an option and that's why
we see the move c5 by alex sanko
still fighting for the center just
without playing b5 just yet
yan follows up now with knight to c3 and
again
b5 is just a little bit premature this
time
knight e5 could still be played uh and
the idea that we had of trading off
this um powerful bishop is is no longer
going to be viable
the best that black can do here is
essentially just to sacrifice in
exchange
and of course that's not exactly what
black is looking for so we still can't
play b5 and that's when we get the move
bishop
e7 by alexianca and this move to my eyes
seems a little bit soft so if you've
been paying attention
the problem with playing b5 has
generally been this
nasty move knight e5 and that's why the
main line here is sort of
aimed at preventing knight e5 from
stopping your idea
of b5 that move of course is queen to c7
now all of a sudden black is controlling
the b7 square
facilitating a bishop b7 idea and is
controlling e5
a little bit more thoroughly so after
the main move
of castles or even d4 we're gonna see
black break out with b5 now
and in this variation we usually see
bishop f4
and simply queen to a7 always
maintaining a grip on the b7 square so
that when knight e5 comes
we simply play bishop b7 and here black
is
pretty much fully equalized and so it's
kind of a mystery to me how alex sanko
plays this bishop e7 move
which is just a slightly more difficult
way
of trying to get this move b5 in we see
castles now by jan napomnishi
and castles by alexenko yan follows up
with this move
d4 and this is where i'm going to say
uh the the opening goes from um
kind of bad to to really even worse
after c
takes d4 black is kind of abandoning any
hope of equalizing here
because now the move b5 is essentially a
pipe dream
we get knight takes d4 and now b5 is
going to be
very very difficult to achieve with
number one this active knight in the
center
number two this bishop bearing down this
now
fully open diagonal and number three uh
the the open d
file nc file are all in white's favor
um so what should um alexenko have done
instead
rather than c takes d4 i'll let you guys
at home try and take a moment to figure
it out here
um black to move here and find an
interesting idea
to try and stay at least in the game
uh okay hopefully you guys came up with
a nice move b5 i think this is the best
chance for black to stay in the game if
we do run into this nasty move knight e5
that i've been talking about
we're simply going to capture this with
black and if bishop takes a it gets
played
c takes d4 is actually a surprisingly
large
amount of compensation for black this
knight is going to have to
leave the c3 square and now all of a
sudden this bishop is a little bit
misplaced
black is rolling through the center and
black
is actually going to be better in this
position now white of course doesn't
have to play knight e5 and there is the
slightly weird looking move knight g5
going for some threats to the king's
side but now after rook a7
black is getting exactly what he wants
in the form of bishop to b7
and is definitely still in this game not
losing
yet so alexenko showing
um that perhaps he didn't calculate
through all these complic
complications quite accurately because
after c takes d4
black really has no hope of equalizing
out of the opening and is going to be in
for a very long and difficult battle in
just a
a great catalan for yawn so we see
knight takes d4
and all the arrows appear back on the
board showing how great white's position
is
uh we see queen c7 by alexenko but it's
a little bit too little too late now
b5 is just not going to happen rook d1
is yan's move rook d8 contesting the d
file
and now bishop e3 and once again you
really see
how far away we are from playing b5
because this bishop
again is attacking a8 so rather than
play a move
like rook a7 or rook b8 both of these
moves just
aren't going to be fast enough white is
just going to take over the center of
the board in the meantime
by the way don't forget about knight c6
you really see
these knights in this bishop
working together just absolutely
eviscerate black's entire position
um so rather than even attempt to go for
b5 in this manner
obviously it's not going to work alex
sanko plays knight b6 instead
hoping for some kind of blockade on d5
rook a to c1
and now alexenko unfortunately has to
more or less has to play this next move
which is just a sign of things going
very very wrong
so in this position i think what
alexander might have been hoping for
is some chance to stick a knight onto
the d5 square
follow that up with b5 and then bishop
b7 and achieve
equality in this manner but after rook a
to c1 we see alexanko sort of give up on
this plan
by playing this move e5 well at first
glance
it looks like this might be a good idea
to activate the remaining light squared
bishop
and in reality it's simply too weakening
on the light squares
black is never going to get this d5
blockade that he was hoping for
and after knight f5 you simply have to
give up this bishop otherwise this
knight is just
way too powerful on f5 and now that the
bishop is gone
we'll see that these light squared
weaknesses around the black king
are what ended up winning the game for
nepo uh the game continues here with
knight c4 so the knights do still have
some life in the position
but after bishop g5 white again is
looking to remove more defenders of the
light squares
we get rook d1 knight d1 keeping an eye
on this b2 pawn
and you know pinning this knight as well
not nothing
rook d8 now is dealing with the pin by
applying some pressure
to the knight on d1 as well and now
simply bishop takes f6
again i always like to say maurice
ashley's favorite move in chess bishop
takes knight
in this case this ultra powerful bishop
is only going to be made
more powerful with each trade of bishops
for knights because the knights defend
the light squares star squared bishop
simply cannot do that so stuff like
bishop e4
is very very nasty in the immediate
future actually
so how do you even meet this threat with
black well
it turns out you simply can't of course
g6 is the hanging of bishop
and h6 isn't really helping your case
with queen h7
being still a very good move in this
instance
simply knight e3 and you have no way of
solving your problems here
so that's why we saw the move queen a5
in this case going
for some checking ideas but after knight
to c3
um it's simply all all uh all fun for
white here just
threat after threat after threat appears
on the board uh
knight d5 now coming after this bishop
on f6
b5 finally gets played but obviously
a bit too much has been given up at this
point queen h7
and black now has to sacrifice the
exchange to avoid getting
you know just absolutely run out of this
game by the way knight takes f6 here was
also a perfectly fine move
but black does get a little bit of
active counter play with queen d2 white
of course though simply winning in this
position as well
queen takes h7 rook d5 bishop d5
and now queen to d2 and this is the
point where
nepo actually had to show some class in
in this game
it's not quite as simple as it might
seem after all these two pieces
are attacked and nepo of course was very
willing to give up this rook
for the night don't be too attached to
the extra material here
white's advantage lies in the fact that
this bishop is very active
very powerful and the black king even
with so few pieces on the board
is never going to be safe as long as
this bishop exists
and that's what we see happen we get b
takes c4
and now e4 by nepo just cements this
bishop in the center of the board
and this king will have no shelter so
long as this bishop lives
uh queen takes b2 by alexsenko might as
well grab some pawns you know die with
the full stomach
uh queen hhh check king e7 now queen c8
and nepo just dancing
on the light squares creating threats
all over the place
uh queen b6 is trying to hold on but now
queen takes c4
nepo again just up a clean pawn f7 is
hanging
and the king is getting checkmated queen
to b5
we now see the check and queen c5 and at
this point alexenko had seen enough
went ahead and resigned the game of
course if you play queen d6
you're gonna get checked again and white
can simply pick up the pawn
race this guy up the board and continue
making threats around the black king
and with this game nepo pulled into
clear
well was already in clear first but
extended his lead in clear first place
staying just a little bit ahead of a
niche geary
right up until the very end so great
game
by nepo and hopefully we all learned a
little something
about why the catalan can be so
dangerous and so scary
that's all i have for you guys today
thank you so much for watching and as
always i will see you
next time